How do I start with this?
So I suck shit at
99.9% things in the world.
(laughter)
And that like a fun thing to
giggle at but it's actually
shockingly true.
I was a solid F
student in school.
And I'm not kidding.
I think when I tell people that
I was D and F student people
laugh like haha because
I've had success
and they think
I mean B's and C's.
No I mean, like Ds and Fs.
Right?
I was really bad at school
mainly because since the time
I can remember
which is three
I've always wanted
to sell stuff.
I'm a businessman
through and through.
And I think about why
have I been able to
be successful even
though everything that led up
to let's say when I was 18 years
old on paper traditionally the
way that we score lent itself to
make people believe that I
wasn't gonna be successful.
And then I started thinking
about the world that we live in.
And then I started
thinking about wow
I'm living in 1% life.
I'm financially
ridiculously secure.
I'm right now I'm focused
on buying the New York Jets.
Right?
Clearly I'm trying to become
a billionaire, I've got all these
great things and why am I
sitting back there and willing
to give up everything that I've
achieved over the last 20 years
we'll call it to trade places
with any one of the
people in this room?
And I was thinking
about why is that.
And why is it really true
and I'm not kind of
giving you bullshit.
Like oh I wish it was you.
I really mean it.
And the reason is because what
I've realized was holy crap we
live in the most ridiculous,
ridiculous era of all time.
This is what I mean.
The cost,
the infrastructure cost
to do what you want to do
for your life has collapsed
over the last 10 years.
There's a thing I don't know
because heard about it,
you may want to
write this down.
There's this thing
called the internet.
Right?
(laughter)
And it's something that wasn't
important or really at scale
when I was your age
only 15 years ago, right?
Really the internet
took off in the US
when Windows 95 came out.
And so it's really only been
about 17 years that the internet
has been a
consumer facing product.
And only really over the
last 5 to 10 at scale.
What the internet has done not
Facebook or Twitter or Tumblr or
Pinterest or Instagram or
Snapchat but the internet itself
has done is create a scenario
where there's really little to
no reason unless you sit through
all of today and I'm going to
apologize because I might ruin
the whole day here right now.
Pay attention to where I'm
going with this, unless you're
obnoxiously obsessed with
the organization and/or person
during the rest
of the day today,
I think you have
to seriously debate
where you are in your
life right now and give
enormous thought to trying to
make the thing that you love the
most in the world work for you.